Welcome to another episode of exciting, deep programming talk with Programming Throwdown. Jason made me feel a little bit sad the other day. He referenced something that we did like a decade ago related to Programming Throwdown. Then it made me realize, oh, that's really good. We've been doing this podcast a long time. And then I got really sad because I'm like, oh, it means I'm old. So no, I'm just kidding. I enjoy doing it. Jason, I know it's great. Okay.
欢迎收听 Programming Throwdown 的又一期精彩、深入的编程访谈节目。前几天，贾森（Jason）让我感到有点伤感。他提到了我们大约十年前做过的一期与 Programming Throwdown 相关的节目。然后我意识到，哦，那真的很好。我们做这个播客已经很久了。然后我变得真的很伤感，因为我想，哦，这意味着我老了。所以，不开玩笑了。我喜欢做这个节目。贾森，我知道这很棒。好吧。
Anyways, that was off topic. So we're here with Aaron today. Welcome to the show, Aaron. Tell us a little bit about yourself, how you got started in programming. Yeah. Thanks for having me, guys. Yeah. I think you started by saying you feel old, so I should really keep quiet on that front.
总之，刚才那段扯远了。所以我们今天请到了阿伦（Aaron）。欢迎来到节目，阿伦。给我们简单介绍一下你自己，以及你是如何开始接触编程的。好的。谢谢你们邀请我。是的。我想你一开始就说觉得自己老了，所以在这方面我真的应该保持安静。
I mean, I started programming keep quiet on that front. I mean, I started programming many, many years ago. I think my first computer was the IBM PC, I think with five megabytes hard drive or something like that. That was like the super duper. You could never fill that up. Yeah, exactly right. And dial up internet and stuff like that. that that has been a long time ago first programming language was basic if you guys even know what that is and so it's been a long time since then i've been doing programming from a young age i don't even know
我是说，我开始编程……在这方面保持安静。我是说，我很多很多年前就开始编程了。我想我的第一台电脑是 IBM PC，好像带有一个 5 兆字节的硬盘之类的。那就像是超级无敌的东西。你永远也装满不了它。是的，完全正确。还有拨号上网之类的东西。那已经是很久以前的事了。第一个编程语言是 BASIC，如果你们甚至知道那是什么的话。所以从那以后已经过去很长时间了。我从小就开始编程，我甚至不知道
since when did undergraduate at Technion CS, then did military service, mandatory in Israel, for six years. What else? PhD, computer science. Went over to the US to do some work on program analysis, program synthesis at IBM Research at the time, TJ Watson Center in New York.
是从什么时候开始的。在以色列理工学院（Technion）读了计算机科学本科，然后在以色列完成了六年的义务兵役。还有什么？计算机科学博士。去了美国，当时在位于纽约托马斯·J·沃森研究中心（TJ Watson Center）的 IBM 研发部门做了一些关于程序分析、程序综合的工作。
And then came back as a faculty of Technion doing machine learning over code, program analysis, program synthesis, all these great things. And during that time, I really got really deep into program synthesis as something that can transform how we write code in reality and not just in academia. And for many, many years, I've been fascinated by the idea of programs that work on programs, compilers, synthesizers, debuggers, any program that operates on other programs. I found that fascinating from a very young age. And this is what I've been doing for a long, long time. Awesome. Well, that was a very sweet moment. I got a lot of stuff, a lot of questions already. So yeah, so starting in BASIC, I mean, I can relate to that.
然后作为教员回到以色列理工学院，从事代码机器学习、程序分析、程序综合以及所有这些很棒的事情。在那期间，我真正深入研究了程序综合，认为它可以改变我们现实中编写代码的方式，而不仅仅局限于学术界。很多很多年里，我都对操作程序的程序（编译器、综合器、调试器，任何对其他程序进行操作的程序）这个想法着迷。我很小的时候就觉得这很迷人。这就是我长期以来一直在做的事情。太棒了。嗯，那是一个非常温馨的时刻。我已经有很多内容、很多问题了。所以，从 BASIC 开始，我是说，我能感同身受。
And then I started in C. And so now that makes me the guy who always has to write the bit shift operations. So, yeah, I mean, that's quite a sweeping thing. So you even in our intro, we're saying that you consider yourself sort of academic or you're teaching. I spent a lot of time in university. I know that's similar to Jason.
然后我从 C 语言开始。所以现在这让我成了那个总是必须编写位移运算的人。所以，是的，这是一个相当全面的说法。因此，你甚至在我们的开场白中也说过，你认为自己有点像学者，或者你在教书。我在大学里花了很长时间。我知道这和贾森很像。
Maybe just a bit before we dig into the other stuff. Like, what are your thoughts for people who are debating, you know, sort of spending extra time in school versus sort of entering the workforce? What are your thoughts about that? We get that question a lot. Yeah, I think I'm quite biased, probably. I think that going to school is great. It really opens your mind and gives you a lot of taste and kind of experience and things
也许在我们深入探讨其他事情之前，你能谈谈对于那些在纠结（你知道的）是花额外时间在学校上学还是直接进入职场的人有什么看法吗？你对此有什么看法？我们经常听到这个问题。是的，我想我可能相当有偏见。我认为上学是很棒的。它真的能开阔你的眼界，并带给你很多品味以及某种体验和事物，
that you would never experience in the workforce, right? Like in a daily job, just because the incentives and the objectives are very different. So I spent four years in undergrad. I think today many programs only require three years. And I think that fourth year in which I did like courses in networks and ai and you know whatever natural language processing and things that you know i would never like even know that these topics exist let alone like go into the depth that you can go in undergrad if i only met them while doing but no like working at a company.
这些是你永远无法在职场中体验到的，对吧？就像在日常工作中一样，只是因为激励机制和目标非常不同。所以我读本科花了四年时间。我认为现在许多项目只需要三年。而我认为第四年我选修了网络、人工智能（你懂得，无论什么自然语言处理）以及那些（你知道的）我甚至永远不会知道这些主题存在的课程，更不用说像如果在大学里那样深入探究了——如果我只是在公司工作时才遇到它们的话。
It's just impossible to get this kind of like wide perspective. And I highly recommend for anyone to just spend this extra year or extra couple of years getting exposed to things because this really changes the way you think about problems. It happens to me very frequently that I bump into some problems and say, but wait, that was something that I actually met in computational biology. There was an algorithm like that in computational biology. And even if I don't remember the details, I kind of have the pointer in my head
要获得这种广阔的视野简直是不可能的。我强烈建议任何人多花这额外的一年或几年时间去接触各种事物，因为这真的会改变你思考问题的方式。我经常会遇到一些问题，然后说：“等等，这其实是我在计算生物学中遇到过的情况。计算生物学中就有这样一种算法。”即使我不记得细节，我的脑海里也算是有了一个线索，
and I can go and look for it and kind of refresh my knowledge about it. So I think that has been like building this kind of reference in your head of all the topics early when you're young and things are really big. It's easy to get them recorded at the infrastructure level of your brain. I think that's super helpful
我可以去寻找它并刷新我对它的知识。所以我认为，在年轻的时候，当事物真正宏大时，在脑海中建立这种所有主题的参考体系是非常容易的。很容易将它们记录在你大脑的基础设施层面。我认为这超级有用，
and it's an investment that really pays itself back very quickly. Nice. Yeah, Thanks for that input. I mean, I think that's something that people debate. I'm not sure there's a right answer, and I think it varies person to person, but I mean, I think that's really good observations.
而且这是一项能非常快得到回报的投资。太好了。是的，谢谢你的观点。我是说，我认为这是人们争论的事情。我不确定是否存在正确答案，而且我认为因人而异，但我认为这真的是很好的观察。
And you said something which I think a lot about, and I know Jason does too, which is this word incentives. And I think it's really interesting to view a lot of things, I don't want to say in life, that sounds too deep, but like a lot of things, at least in, you know, interacting with people at work and thinking about incentives. For me, that's been something that helps explain a lot.
你刚才说了一点，我经常思考，我也知道贾森也是如此，那就是“激励机制（incentives）”这个词。我认为，从激励机制的角度来看待很多事情（我不想说在生活中，那听起来太深奥了，但至少在很多事情上，比如在工作中与人交往）是非常有趣的。对我来说，这是有助于解释很多事情的事情。
And so as you point out, when you're in school, I think your incentives are very different than when you're in the workplace. And I think, like you said, the experiences you'll have, even just thinking in that lens, you can sort of understand how they may be starkly different. I think it's important to understand that every endeavor at the end is a human endeavor. So research is, and the workplace is, and people are at the end motivated by, even if the incentives or the kind of target functions are very implicit, they are there.
正如你所指出的，当你在学校时，我认为你的激励机制与你在职场时非常不同。而且我认为，就像你说的，你将拥有的经历，甚至只要通过这个视角去思考，你就能在某种程度上理解它们可能会有何等鲜明的不同。我认为重要的是要明白，任何事业归根结底都是一项人类的事业。所以研究是，职场也是，而人们最终的驱动力——即使激励机制或目标函数非常隐式——它们也是存在的。
And in the workplace, you're supposed to get something done at the end, right? A kind way of saying humans are greedy. Yes. No, no, it's not greedy. I think it's not greedy. It's natural, right? That's true.
而在职场中，你最终应该把事情做好，对吧？用一种委婉的方式说就是人类是贪婪的。是的。不，不，这不是贪婪。我认为这不是贪婪。这是自然的，对吧？确实如此。
Greedy ascribes some sort of moral aspect to it, I guess. Yeah, exactly. All right. So, you know, we talked about in Jason's intro, he said that this is going to be AI for code. So, I mean, I think talking about how code development works and even in your sort of like introduction talk, you talked about synthesis analysis program. So back when I was first writing QBasic and, you know, sort of input introduction talk to you talked about synthesis analysis programming so back when i was first writing cube basic and you know sort of inputting that and like line 10 go to you know
贪婪赋予了它某种道德层面的东西，我想。是的，完全正确。好的，那么，我们谈到了贾森的开场白，他说这将是针对代码的人工智能。所以，我认为谈论代码开发是如何工作的，甚至在你的开场白中，你也谈到了综合、分析程序。所以，当我在编写最初的 QBasic 时，你知道的，那种输入……开场白里你谈到了综合、分析编程。所以当我在编写最初的 QBasic 时，你知道的，那种输入，就像第 10 行转到，你知道的，
10 whatever i wrote an infinite okay anyways you know it was just an editor the editor was very simple i don't even remember recall it having syntax highlighting um you know that was sort of the it may have had i can't remember now it's been too long those early days and we're starting to drop some of those words so everyone kind of i get i think understands you open uh vi emacs notepad.exe just depending on your on your platform and you start putting like things that represent a program as text into that that sheet and that that's sort of everywhere everywhere starts and then sort of take us on how you think about, you know, I think there's a lot more than just editing the code,
10 随便什么，我写了一个无限的……好吧，不管怎样，你知道的，它只是一个编辑器。编辑器非常简单。我甚至不记得它是否有语法高亮显示。嗯，这算是一种……它可能曾经有过，我现在记不清了，那已经是早期的事情太久了。我们开始抛出其中一些词汇，所以每个人大概，我想，都能理解你打开 vi、emacs、notepad.exe（取决于你的平台），然后你开始把代表程序的文本内容放入那个工作表，这就是一切的起点。然后引导我们思考你如何看待，你知道的，我认为除了编辑代码之外还有更多内容，
but maybe starting there, like for me at least, well, maybe it starts before and how you think about what you want to put on the paper as it were, or we want to put down. But maybe take us through a little bit like how you think about those early days
但也许可以从那里开始，比如对我和我而言，或者也许它开始于更早的时候，以及你如何思考你想在纸上或我们要写下的内容。但也许可以带我们了解一下你是如何看待那些早期的日子，
and how it was approached so that we can sort of set up how it's sort of undergoing some amount of transformation. Yeah, I think it's all a question of balance between the human and the machine, in a sense. In the early, early days, you had to work really hard to satisfy the requirements of the machine. And the machine was kind of brutally unforgiving, right? Like you could make one single mistake, nothing told you that you made that mistake
以及当时是如何处理的，这样我们就可以为它正在经历一定程度的转变做好铺垫。是的，从某种意义上说，这完全是人和机器之间平衡的问题。在非常非常早期的日子里，你必须非常努力地工作来满足机器的要求。而且机器可以说是冷酷无情、毫不留情的，对吧？比如你可能犯了一个错误，没有任何东西告诉你你犯了这个错误，
and the whole thing would go awry when you run it, right? And so over the years, people had this brilliant idea. I think Fortran was the first, that you can use the machine to help the human deal with the machine, which is, I think, the idea behind the compiler. The early compiler is exactly that, like help the human write something that is slightly higher level. The compiler will do some work to check it and maybe give you some useful errors.
当你运行它时，整个程序就会出问题，对吧？所以在多年里，人们有了一个绝妙的想法。我想 Fortran 是第一个，你可以利用机器来帮助人类处理机器，这也就是编译器的理念所在。早期的编译器正是如此，帮助人类编写稍微高级一点的东西。编译器会做一些工作来检查它，也许会给你一些有用的错误提示。
And then the machine would run it for you. And so this is kind of really the early idea of having a machine help the human program it and making it more forgiving in a sense. Yeah, I was right there. So maybe people don't realize or know. I mean, I wasn't exposed to it initially and then found out later. But so originally, people would write literally the hex codes for assembly or no i mean i wasn't exposed to it initially and then found out later but so originally people would write literally the hex codes for assembly to like you know basically script the exact flipping of the gates inside the microprocessor oh this is my background i'll get here all day
然后机器会为你运行它。所以这真的是让机器帮助人类编程并使其在某种程度上更具容错性的早期理念。是的，我就经历过。所以也许人们没有意识到或不知道。我是说，我最初没有接触到它，后来才发现。但是最初，人们会直接为汇编编写十六进制代码，或者……我是说，我最初没有接触到它，后来才发现。但是最初，人们会直接为汇编编写十六进制代码，比如……你知道的，基本上是编写微处理器内部逻辑门精确翻转的脚本。哦，这是我的背景，我会在这里说个没完，
so i'm not going to talk about this but like you know actually writing hex that is stored in an e-prom or or whatever and the you know the c CPU actually executes was like, step zero, the very first people had nothing else, I guess that's what you kind of got to do, right? Then people realize, oh, hey, hang on, we can use I believe the word is mnemonics, right? Like, I can say hex code, this is actually the word MOV move, right? And why it wasn't longer, yeah, someone else, but like, MOV, you know, branch if equal b and e branch not equal right like these all these stuff and moving the registers and still thinking about the physicality of the compiler then then the very early thing was like a two-pass assembler right so like i could use labels so i
所以我不会谈论这个，但就像实际上编写存储在 EPROM 或其他设备中的十六进制代码，然后 CPU 实际执行，这就像是第零步，最初的人们别无选择，我想这就是你不得不做的事情，对吧？然后人们意识到，哦，嘿，等等，我们可以使用，我相信这个词是助记符（mnemonics），对吧？就像，我可以写十六进制代码，这实际上就是 MOV 这个词，移动，对吧？为什么它不更长一点，是的，其他人，但像 MOV，你知道的，如果相等则分支 bne（branch not equal）分支不等，对吧？所有这些东西，移动寄存器，仍然在思考编译器的物理特性，然后非常早期的东西就像是一个两趟汇编器（two-pass assembler），所以就像我可以使用标签，
could use a label for a line number or an address and use something else in the compiler would scan through once pick up all your labels figure out where they go and then scan through again super super low level and so so what you're talking about fortran this idea that like you don't need to write like one-to-one assembly instructions was like yeah i think i agree like a very early breakthrough in in how to get the machine to do the work that you really didn't need to be doing yeah i think since, I think there's been a lot more kind of development in how the machine can help you. You mentioned syntax highlighting earlier, but also all sorts of more sophisticated compilers
所以我可以为行号或地址使用标签，并在编译器中做其他事情，它会扫描一遍，挑选出你所有的标签，弄清楚它们要去哪里，然后再扫描一遍。超级超级底层。所以，你谈论的 Fortran，这种不需要编写一对一汇编指令的想法就像是，是的，我认为我同意，这是关于如何让机器做你实际上不需要亲自去做的那些工作的早期重大突破。是的，我认为自那以后，
that can give you really deep error messages on what you did wrong. And also linters and static analysis that can point out common errors and maybe even suggest corrections and all these things that make our lives easier. But at the end, at the very end, programming is still extremely unforgiving, right? If you compare it to having a conversation in natural language, it's still like you can spend the whole day, you know, like flipping
我认为在机器如何帮助你方面有了更多种类的发展。你刚才提到了语法高亮显示，还有各种更复杂的编译器，它们可以针对你的错误提供非常深入的错误信息。还有检查常见错误并甚至可以建议修正的代码检查器（linters）和静态分析，以及所有这些让我们的生活更轻松的事情。但最终，在最根本上，编程仍然极其冷酷无情，对吧？如果你把它与用自然语言进行对话相比，它仍然是……你可能会花上一整天，你知道的，像翻转一样，
because you flipped two parameters to a function or just forgot the semicolon somewhere, right? And this is like extremely unforgiving, even today. And it's been a while since Fortran, yeah. Oh, that's true. Okay, so I think people probably know like what syntax highlighting is,
因为你弄错了函数的两个参数，或者只是在某个地方忘记了一个分号，对吧？这简直是毫不留情的，即使在今天也是如此。而且距离 Fortran 诞生已经过去很久了，是的。哦，那是真的。好吧，所以我想人们大概知道什么是语法高亮显示，
and if they've had any experience, they probably kind of get that. So static analysis, though, maybe can you explain what static analysis is? Yeah, in essence, it's really kind of like an expansion of the compiler to check properties that are more than maybe just type checking or the standard things that the compiler checks to more sophisticated things maybe properties like i know your program does not divide by zero or you
如果他们有任何经验，他们大概能理解。那么静态分析，你能解释一下什么是静态分析吗？是的，本质上它其实就像是编译器的一种扩展，用来检查那些不仅仅是类型检查或编译器检查的标准属性，而是更复杂的属性，比如，我知道你的程序不会除以零，或者
don't have an alt reference or no overflow and properties of that nature and all the way to like full program verification which is checking that your program satisfies kind of a functional logical specification, you know, that a given function that is supposed to sort an array actually returns an array that is sorted and check that statically, meaning without running the program, right? So the static part here means that i'm not going to run the program i'm going to statically check it at compile time and give it
你不会有空引用，也不会溢出，以及具有这种性质的属性。一直到完整的程序验证，也就是检查你的程序是否满足某种功能逻辑规范，你知道的，比如一个理应用来对数组进行排序的给定函数实际上返回了一个已排序的数组，并且静态地检查这一点，这意味着无需运行程序，对吧？所以这里的“静态”部分意味着我不会运行程序，我将在编译时对其进行静态检查并给出结果。
a result and now some of the listeners may like scratch their head and say like but wait this sounds like something that is undecidable because if they've heard about kind of the whole the whole thing problems say like wait can you check that the program terminates probably you cannot and so indeed the problem is undecidable but you can solve approximations of this problem and typically the way that standing analysis works is that it gives you conservative errors or conservative reports, meaning that if it says that there is no error, then it's guaranteed to be correct,
现在，一些听众可能会抓耳挠腮并说：“但是等等，这听起来像是某种不可判定（undecidable）的问题，因为如果他们听说过整个停机问题，就会说：‘等等，你能检查程序是否会终止吗？大概不能。’”因此，这个问题确实是不可判定的，但你可以解决该问题的近似值，并且静态分析的工作方式通常是给你保守的错误或保守的报告，这意味着如果它说没有错误，那么它保证是正确的，
but it may give you false alarms saying, hey, your program may divide by zero, which actually doesn't. And so that has been quite useful at the end. But it is also often quite frustrating for developers because they chase down all sorts of reports that turn out to be false alarms. And that can be really frustrating.
但它可能会给你错误的警报，说：“嘿，你的程序可能会除以零”，而实际上并没有。所以这最终证明是非常有用的。但对于开发人员来说，这也常常相当令人沮丧，因为他们去追查各种结果证明是误报的报告。这可能会真的很令人沮丧。
So I think, yeah, I mean, so I've run static analysis before. And I mean, I think the compiler does, you know, some form of static analysis. And even now, like the better, but like separate tools often, you know, go in more depth. And this frustration you're expressing is, was sort of my experience that you get a lot of stuff where it sort of just gets confused, which already we're sort of talking about the computer doing more and talking about getting confused or not understanding and we're talking somewhat about like humans have some intent when they write their code but then how they express it may not match and then something else is trying to like understand it so when we say like the computer tries to understand what you're trying to do or tries to check for a divide by zero? Like, what are we actually meaning there? So, yeah, without like getting all academic here, I think the right view is that the static analyzer or the machine, let's call it, is constructing some obstruction of your program
所以我想，是的，我是说，我以前运行过静态分析。而且，我认为编译器确实做了某种形式的静态分析。甚至现在，更好但独立的工具经常会深入挖掘。你所表达的这种沮丧情绪，正是我的经历，你会得到很多东西，它在其中只是变得一团糟，这已经让我们开始谈论计算机做更多的事情，并谈论它变得糊涂或不理解，我们有点在讨论人类在编写代码时有一些意图，但他们表达它的方式可能不匹配，然后别的东西试图去理解它。所以当我们说“计算机试图理解你在试图做什么”或者“试图检查除以零”时，我们实际上是什么意思？所以，是的，不用在这里搞得太学术化，我认为正确的看法是，静态分析器或机器（我们姑且这么称呼它）正在构建你程序的一些抽象，
that it can reason about. And that obstruction does not always match your idea of what the program does. And this is where the confusion or the mismatch comes from. And it's also the reason that sometimes or often these tools cannot explain why they got what they got, right? Or not in a way that you would understand it, not in a way that would be useful for the human.
它可以对这些抽象进行推理。而那个抽象并不总是符合你对程序做什么的想法。这就是困惑或不匹配产生的地方。这也是为什么这些工具有时或经常无法解释它们为什么会得出那个结论的原因，对吧？或者说无法以你能理解的方式，无法以对人类有用的方式。
So the chain of reasoning that led them to the conclusion that you are amazed by or shocked by is not easily explainable to human. But you're spot on in the point of kind of understanding the intent and communicating intent to the machine. And all these questions are really central, both for program analysis and program synthesis. How do you know what is it that the human was trying to do? I mean, I think like when I tried to explain to people who aren't in programming, like what debugging or what these things are like, I just get blank stares. But I mean,
因此，导致它们得出让你惊叹或震惊的结论的推理链，并不容易向人类解释。但你在理解意图和向机器传达意图这一点上是一针见血的。所有这些问题对于程序分析和程序综合来说都是核心问题。你怎么知道人类到底在尝试做什么？我是说，我认为就像当我试图向不从事编程的人解释什么是调试或这些事情是什么样的时候，我得到的只是茫然的凝视。但我是说，
for people who have programmed a lot, I think a lot of people experience that where you write some code, you have some intent, you run it. And even it turns out that actually the computer got it right and you got it wrong, that you thought, you know, a number, you code it better than you like solved your own problem. And I think for me, the interesting thing about, you know, static analysis, or even just compilers adding that to their repertoire over the years
对于经常编程的人来说，我认为许多人都经历过那种情况：你写了一些代码，你有某种意图，你运行它。甚至结果证明其实计算机是对的，你是错的，你以为（你知道的）一个数字，你编写的代码比你解决自己的问题还要好。而且我认为对我来说，关于静态分析（或者仅仅是多年来编译器将这一点加入到它们的技能库中）有趣的事情是，你一次可以在脑海中容纳的事物的数量。所以函数之间的交互，以及（你知道的）“哦，嘿，你在这里调用了这个东西，它有这个或那个”。它真的……嗯，我来自 C/C++ 背景。所以，对吧，对我来说就像是：这个函数会不会返回一个空指针？好吧，如果它很简单，也许它永远不会返回空指针，除非传入了一个空指针。你知道的，你就可以开始
is like the number of things you can hold in your head at one time. So the interaction between functions and that, you know, oh, hey, you're calling this thing over here and it has this or that. And did it really is, well, I come from a CC++ background. So like, you know, for me, it'd be like, can this function ever return a null pointer? Well, if it's simple, maybe it can never return a null pointer unless a null pointer was provided into it. You know, you can kind of start
跟踪所有这些事情。我们知道计算机非常擅长（你知道的）非常快地重复做事情。所以在脑海中容纳所有这些简单的函数……我们知道计算机非常擅长非常快地重复做事情。所以在脑海中容纳所有这些简单的函数，它就可以进行那种边界检查，比如这能得到的最大数字是多少？它是溢出还是下溢？即使它不能告诉你你是对的还是错的，我所看到的有用之处是那种合作，它会回来告诉你：“嘿，根据我在这里看到的情况，这是你可以从这个输出中预期的数值范围。”这就是你开始看到的时候，哦，等待，实际上有这种迭代的事情，
keeping track of all of those things. And we know a computer is really great at, you know, doing, you know, repetitive things very quickly. And so holding all of those simple functions And we know a computer is really great at doing repetitive things very quickly. And so holding all of those simple functions in its head, it can do those sort of bounds checking, like what is the biggest number that this could get? Is it an overflow or underflow? And even if it can't tell you you're right or wrong, what I've seen be useful is that sort of cooperation where it sort of come back and tells you like, hey, based on what I see here right now, this is the range of values you can sort of expect out of this. And that's when you sort of start to see, oh, wait, there's actually this like, iterative thing where
我在做某事，计算机告诉我它认为我打算做什么，我告诉它（你知道的），你就会这样做……现在这更多地发生在我身上，因为错误信息越来越好，等等，与我刚开始的时候相比，我发现自己做的事情是运行（你知道的）庞大的代码块，（你知道的）试图将程序作为一个整体运行，然后看看最后是否会出来正确的东西。绝对是这样。
I'm doing something, the computer's telling me what it thinks I meant to do, I'm telling it that, you know, and you sort of do this happens to me, I guess more now, as like the error messages are getting better, and whatever, versus when I first started out, what I would find myself doing is running, you know, enormous blocks of code and, you know, trying to run the program as a whole and just see if the right thing comes out at the end. Absolutely.
所以这正是我们看到的进展——人和机器之间的这种紧密循环，人类在做某事。机器在给你反馈。现在，本质上，多年来，我们在编写程序时越来越接近于与机器协同工作。你所描述的实际上是规范的迭代发现。
So that's exactly the progress that we're seeing this tight loop between the human and the machine, that the human is doing something. The machine is like giving you feedback. And now, essentially, over the years, we are getting closer and closer to working together with the machine when you write the program. What you described effectively is the iterative discovery of the specification.
当你开始编程时，你对它应该做什么有一个松散的想法，但是……当你开始编程时，你对它应该做什么有一个松散的想法，但你并没有所有的边界检查和所有的微妙之处，因为（你知道的）你从高层思想、高层规范开始。随着你编写代码，你开始发现并解开其中包含的低级细节和隐藏的复杂性。你所描述的是机器……随着你编写代码，你开始发现并解开其中包含的低级细节和隐藏的复杂性。
When you start programming, you have a loose idea of what it should do, but you start programming, you have kind of a loose idea of what it should do, but you don't have all kind of the edge cases and all the subtleties because, you know, you start with high-level thought of high-level spec. And as you write the code, you start to discover and unravel kind of the low-level details and the hidden complexity that is in there. And what you described is the machine kind of the low-level details and the hidden complexity that is in there.
而你所描述的是机器在你在取得进展时帮助你解开这些。我认为这也是综合发挥作用的地方，这个想法是，如果你足够清晰地表达你的意图，机器实际上可以从你的意图和上下文中预测你试图做什么，并为你完成代码或完成思考，这种方式还可以防止你陷入该领域的标准或常见陷阱。
And what you described is the machine kind of helping you unravel that as you make that progress. And I think this is also where synthesis comes in, which is the idea that if you express your intent clearly enough, the machine can actually predict what is it that you are trying to do from your intent and from context and complete the code or complete the thought for you in a way that also kind of prevents you from falling into the standard or like the common pitfalls around that area.
是的，这讲得通。我认为程序综合变得重要的地方之一，在于弄清楚哪些假设是重要的，哪些是不重要的。在可能最大的整数上，现在你的程序将无法工作或将溢出。这就好比，是的，这可能会发生，但它没用，对吧？所以它正如你所说，变成了这种共生的东西。因此我认为最大的挑战之一是如何知道什么样的错误对人们有用。这似乎是所有魔法发生的地方。没错。
Yeah, that makes sense. I think one of the things that is really, I think, where program synthesis becomes important is in figuring out all of the assumptions that matter and the ones that don't. in the biggest possible integer ever, and now your program will not work or will overflow. And it's like, okay, yes, that could have happened, but it's not useful, right? And so it becomes, as you said, this symbiotic thing. And so I think one of the big challenges is how to know what sort of errors are useful for people. That seems to be kind of where all the magic has to happen. Right.
我认为这正是让我对程序综合感到兴奋的原因，而不是那些静态分析工具。所以我已经从事静态分析工具的工作……我不知道，好几年，很多年。正如你所说，与静态分析工具的这种共生关系相当棘手，因为你有了这样一个总是抱怨的东西，抱怨那些……就像是“嘿，我根本不在乎那个。”
And I think this is exactly why I got excited by program synthesis as opposed to kind of the static analysis tools. So I've worked for, I don't know, several, many years on static analysis tools. And really, as you said, the symbiotic thing with static analysis tools is quite tricky because you have this thing that is always complaining and complaining about things that are kind of like, hey, I don't care about that.
那根本不是这里的问题。所以它最终分散了你的注意力，而不是帮助你。所以它是一种共生物。但就像有一个挑剔鬼在抱怨不重要的东西，把我从实际的事情中分散注意力，打断我的思路，对吧？这就是为什么我认为这是喜欢不断抱怨的消极工具所面临的挑战。这也是为什么我发现程序综合如此引人注目的原因，因为它说：“等一下，我看到你在做什么了。这对你可能真的很有帮助，比如这段信息或下一行代码。”
That's not the problem here at all. And so it actually ends up distracting you more than helping you. So it's a symbiotic thing. But there's like this nitpicker that is like complaining about the immaterial stuff and distracting me from my actual thing and breaking my train of thought, right? And this is why I think that's the challenge with negative tools that complain all the time. And this is why I find program synthesis so compelling because it says, hang around, I see what you're doing. This may be really helpful for you, like this piece of information or this next line of code.
我说：“你知道吗？我不在乎。让我继续打字。就像，我正处于顺境中，所以我继续打字。我甚至都不会注意到。”甚至都不知道这个，但如果我被卡住了额外的一小会儿，我看着工具的建议并说：“哦，是的，这正是我想要的。谢谢你，亲爱的程序综合。”我可以采纳这个并继续前进。所以它不是在抱怨，而是在提供建议。我想也许最简单的类比就像是，假设手机上不是自动完成（type ahead），而是一个在你犯拼写错误时总是抱怨的拼写检查器。
And I say, you know what? I don't care. Let me keep on typing. I'm like, I'm on a roll, so I'll keep on typing. I won't even notice. even know this, but if I'm stuck for this extra fraction of a second, and I look at the suggestion of the tool and say, oh, yeah, that's exactly what I wanted. Thank you, dear program synthesis, and I can consume this and keep on going. So rather than complaining, it is suggesting things. And I think maybe the simplest analogy is kind of like assume that instead of type ahead on your phone, you had just a spell checker that complains all the time when you make the typing mistakes.
对吧。所以自动完成要有用得多。对吧。是的，我是说，我想举一个非常具体的例子。所以，你知道的，贾森的那个东西，我只是写了一个名为（你知道的）increment 或 plus one 的函数。然后，这个东西在抱怨，到处都是波浪线，写着潜在的溢出、没有边界检查之类的东西。就像你说的那样，这真的很烦人。我想，随着程序员的进步，甚至他们对它的理解，他们想做什么，正如贾森指出的那样，我会觉得：“是的，这其实不太实用。我其实不在乎。”但另一方面，
Right. And so type ahead is infinitely more useful. Right. Yeah, I mean, I think like to take like a very specific example, I guess. So, you know, Jason's thing, like I just write a function called, you know, increment or plus one. And, you know, the thing is complaining, squiggling lines everywhere, being like potential overflow, like no bounds checking, whatever. Like you're right, that's really annoying. And I guess there's like,
我知道这是一个风险。如果我们开始讨论组件如何以意想不到的方式被重用，如果我正在使用的工具说：“嘿，实际上，让我为你添加边界检查”，那么除非它是性能关键的，再次回到我的背景，我可能会让它这样做，对吧？比如，如果等于 int max，（你知道的）什么都不做。好吧，至少它没有递增，但至少它不会（你知道的）溢出，
as programmers progress or even like their understanding of it, what they want to do, as Jason pointed out, I'm going to be like, yeah, that's not really practical. I don't really care. But on the flip side,
并给我一个比我放入的数字还要小的数字。所以我至少可以说（你知道的）现在我知道这个函数永远不会（你知道的）缩减而只会增长，但在某些小情况下可能相等。因此，正如你所说，拥有综合实际上在某些方面应用起来很有用，但更复杂，因为你首先需要了解存在问题，并了解一个可接受的解决方案，比如“嘿，这里一个可接受的解决方案
I know that is a risk. And if we start talking about like how components get reused in ways that didn't get expected, if the tool that I'm using says, you know, hey, actually, let me add in the bounds check for you, then unless it's performance critical, again, my background, I'll probably let it do it, right? Like, oh, if equal to int max, you know, just do nothing. Like, okay, well, at least it didn't increment, but at least it doesn't, you know, overflow
是进行边界检查并什么都不做，或者进行边界检查并抛出异常”，以及我处于什么框架中，我处于什么语言中，我猜这可能会有很大差异。从某种意义上说，它确实更复杂，但它也更符合你的心流，对吧？所以抽象地说你是对的，我需要了解更多，但在某种程度上我需要采取更少的行动。我需要看一下它并说：“是的，
and give me a number smaller than what I put in. So I can at least say that, you know, now I know this function never, you know, shrinks and only grows, but maybe is equal in some small case. And so having the synthesis, like you say, is actually in some ways applying it useful, more complicated because you first need to understand there's a problem and understand like an acceptable solution that like hey an acceptable solution here
我不关心这个。”然而对于静态分析，我必须为了满足工具的要求而工作，对吧？因为我必须（你知道的）忽略该东西上的边界检查，或者我必须积极地做点什么来让这些东西停止抱怨。
is to balance check and do nothing to balance check and throw an exception uh and what framework i'm in what language i'm in i guess like that could vary wildly yeah a sense, it is kind of more complex, but it's also more in your flow, right? So abstractly you're correct that I need to understand more, but I need to act less in a sense. I need to look at it and say, yeah,
我认为这就是许多人对此感到沮丧的地方。我认为综合可以说是许多这类问题的解药。你是否发现（你知道的）当你谈论静态分析或综合时，我的意思是，有些语言不再那么大量使用了，所以也许可以排除那些，但在人们每天都会遇到的语言中，你是否发现
I don't care about this. And like, whereas with the static thing, I'll have to work for the tool to satisfy it, right? Because I'll have to like, and ignore bounce check on the thing, or I'll have to do something actively to make these things stop complaining.
人们对这些工具的接受度会根据他们使用的语言类型或他们正在进行的开发类型而有所不同？还是人们普遍对计算机给予他们更多帮助持开放态度？是的，人们非常开放。我认为大约有底层的 5% 的开发人员，你知道的，那些真正非常年轻、不知道发生了什么的人，
And I think that is the frustration that a lot of people have around that. I think synthesis is kind of like the cure for a lot of these things. Do you find like, you know, when you talk about static analysis or or synthesis do you i mean like some languages aren't used so heavily anymore so maybe excluding those but of languages that people would encounter every day do you find that like
会被综合工具搞得非常困惑，或者潜在地感到困惑，因为他们得到了这些建议，而他们不知道自己得到的是什么以及为什么。所以这有点像，这将是棘手的。而顶尖的 1% 的开发人员，他们正在进行设备驱动程序开发、一次性事情、算法开发等等，这些建议可能不会切中要害，因为他们的意图是如此一次性且复杂，以至于这与人们编写代码的任何常见分布都不匹配。
people's acceptance of of those kinds of tools varies based on like the kind of language they're using or the kind of development they're doing? Or are people generally pretty open to having the computer help them out more? Yeah, I think people are very open. I think there's kind of like the bottom 5% of developers know the really, really new ones who don't know what's going on
所以要么他们需要针对设备驱动程序开发的一些专门模型，这几乎就像是它自己的语言，对吧？它就像它自己的一套习惯用法；要么他们宁愿不使用任何工具，因为（你知道的）他们在 vi 中工作，以及围绕它的所有刻板印象，对吧？所以，我是说，我想我们以前有过关于编辑器的辩论。我想甚至在这个节目中我们也谈论过。而且我认为人们会随着时间改变。我认为你可以获得很多工具
are going to get really confused by synthesis tools or potentially confused because they're getting these suggestions and they don't know what is it that they're getting and why. So it's kind of like, it's going to be tricky. And the top like 1% of developers who are doing device driver development, one-off thing, algorithmic, this or that, the suggestions are not going to be probably on target because their intent is so one-off and complicated that this doesn't match any of the common distributions of how people write code.
来做很多事情，这取决于你愿意在这上面花多少精力。但对我来说，我所意识到的我现在所处的位置，至少是这种计算机合作，也就是，计算机非常简单，比如“嘿，有这个函数，这个函数是从哪里来的？”有时它实际上证明并不是我
So either they would need some specialized model for device driver development which is kind of like almost its own language right it's like its own set of idioms or they would rather not use any tools because also you know they work in vi and all the stereotypes around that right so, I mean, I think like we've had those editor debates before. I think even on this show, we've talked about it. And I think people change over time. And I think you can get lots of tools
以为的那个函数，它是从其他地方拉取过来的。并且在使用过各种工具之后，有时这是一个基于（你知道的）代码匹配的猜测。有时它实际上是基于（你知道的）理解它是如何构建的。这引导着我，我正要去某个地方。那就是，在不同的平台、不同的代码库、不同的框架中，有很多差异。工具是如何……我们说过构建了一个抽象，但它是……比如从操作上讲，工具是如何……我们说过构建了一个抽象，但它是
to do lots of things, depending on how much you're willing to sort of spend on it. But for me, the realization I've had of where I am now, at least, is this computer cooperation, which is, again, that the computer, just as simple as, hey, there's this function, where is this function coming from? And sometimes it actually turns out it wasn't the function I
……比如从操作上讲，这是如何工作的？如果我们有用 C++、Java、Python 编写的程序——这种中间表示是否足够通用，以便在所有这些程序中发挥作用并进行推理，并且它是进出这些东西的前端和后端，还是我们需要某种有所不同的理解（你知道的，正如我们所说，对于设备驱动程序，你可能需要完全不同的东西）？其中每一个场景有多常见或有多独特？所以，是的，在抽象层面上讨论这一点很难，所以我认为我们需要将其具象化一点。因此，大多数综合工具（或者我们称之为代码 AI 工具）确实具有某些特定于语言的语义方面。
thought it was, it's pulling it from somewhere else. And having used various tools, sometimes that is a guess based on, you know, code match. And sometimes it's based on actually, you know, understanding how it's being built. And this is leading me, I am going somewhere. And that is that, you know, across the different platforms, different code bases, different frameworks, there's a lot of difference. How does the tooling sort of like, we said builds an abstraction, but is it like just like operationally, how does the tooling sort of like we said builds an abstraction but is it uh like just like operationally how does that work if we have programs in c++ java python like is that
它们有一些，我们称之为提取程序，从语言中提取某种表示、解释性表示，其中包括关于类型的信息、变量之间如何流动数据的信息，以及一些其他东西，这些是特定于语言的，它们将其提取到公共表示中，就像编译器在为后端生成代码之前所做的一样。所以对于那些不知道（你知道的）GCC 或类似东西的人来说，就像标准编译器一样，它们可能有许多前端和许多后端，但它们通过提取或首先将前端语言或源语言翻译成某种解释性表示来进行通信，然后后端基于此工作。
intermediate common enough to be useful and reasoned about you know across all of them and it's you know front ends and back ends into and out of those things or do we need sort of like some understanding that differs you know like were saying, for a device driver, you might need something just entirely different. How common or unique are each of those scenarios? So, yeah, it's hard to discuss this in the abstract, so I think we need to concretize it a bit more. So most of the synthesis tools or let's say the AI for code tools do have some semantic aspects that are language specific.
因此，类似于该模型，标准分析工具或程序综合工具通常也有提取一些语义信息到解释性表示中的前端，然后整个后端都基于此工作。所以，是的，有一些特定于语言的（我们称之为）特征，但大部分机制是与语言无关的。原来如此。所以除了知道 GCC 是 GCC 之外，我对 GCC 知之甚少。
They have some, let's call it extraction procedure that extracts some representation, interpretive presentation from the language, which includes information about maybe types, maybe how data flows between variables, maybe some other things, which is quite language specific, and they extract it to a common presentation, much like a compiler does before it generates code for the backend. So for people who don't know like, you know, GCC or something like that, like standard compilers, they may have a lot of frontends and a lot of backends, but they communicate by extracting or by first translating the frontend language or the source language into some interpretive presentation and the backend works of that.
它们有一些，我们称之为提取的过程，从语言中提取出某种表示、解释性的表示，其中可能包含关于类型的信息、变量之间的数据流向，或者其他一些高度依赖于特定语言的东西。它们将其提取为一种通用的表示，就像编译器在为后端生成代码之前所做的那样。所以对于那些不了解标准编译器（比如 GCC 之类的人）来说，它们可能有很多前端和很多后端，但它们的通信方式是通过提取，或者首先将前端语言或源语言翻译成某种解释性的表示，然后后端基于此进行工作。
So similar to that model, standard analysis tool or program synthesis tools also have typically front-ends that extract some semantic information to an interpretive presentation and then the entire backend works of that. So yeah, there are some language-specific, let's call them features, but most of the machinery is language-agnostic. I see. So I don't know too much about GCC other than it's GCC.
与该模型类似，标准分析工具或程序综合工具通常也有前端，它们将一些语义信息提取为解释性表示，然后整个后端基于此工作。所以是的，有一些特定于语言的、我们称之为特性的东西，但大部分机制是与语言无关的。我明白了。所以我对 GCC 的了解不多，只知道它是 GCC。
So we can talk about Clang, and then I'd like to contrast it with like JVM or, you know, Python. So for many languages that can be compiled by Clang, Clang has this IR, this intermediate representation. And it's actually a very powerful thing because anything you can get into the intermediate representation, you can get machine code out for any backend that Clang supports. So, you know, PowerPC, x86, ARM, you know, whatever your specific, and if you want to write a new, you know, host system, it's just as simple as, you know, writing another one of these backends. And then optimizations can take place in this intermediate represent. Okay. So Java has something, I guess, a bit similar, right? You compiled to this sort of the bytecode and other machines can target to that bytecode. I don't know what it is for Python. But once they're in these representations, and we're sort of at that, you know, intermediate, how similar are like the programming constructs in Python? I've never really thought about it, like in Python, versus, you know, Java versus sort of like, what would have come out of C++? Yeah, I don't think they're necessarily very similar at that level, but kind of the concepts of dynamic binding or all these kind of like fundamental program language concepts are there.
所以我们可以谈谈 Clang，然后我想把它和 JVM，或者说 Python 做个对比。对于许多可以由 Clang 编译的语言来说，Clang 拥有这种 IR，即中间表示。这其实是一个非常强大的特性，因为任何你能转化为中间表示的东西，都可以针对 Clang 支持的任何后端生成机器码。所以，你知道的，PowerPC、x86、ARM，不管你的具体需求是什么，如果你想编写一个新的宿主系统，这就像编写另一个后端一样简单。然后优化就可以在这个中间表示中进行。好吧。所以我想 Java 有点类似的东西，对吧？你编译成这种字节码，然后其他机器可以针对该字节码。我不知道 Python 是怎样的。但一旦它们变成这些表示形式，当我们处于那种中间阶段时，Python 中的编程结构有多相似？我从没真正想过，比如 Python 与 Java，或者与 C++ 会产生的东西相比？是的，我不认为它们在那个层面上一定非常相似，但动态绑定或所有这些基本的编程语言概念之类的概念都在那里。
The modeling can be quite involved. For example, if you've ever looked at how Scala is compiled to the JVM, if you had the kind of, I guess, maybe misfortune of looking into these details, this is extremely, extremely involved. It's really beautiful conceptual and engineering work by the Scala team. It's really amazing, but it's really beautiful conceptual and engineering work by the Scala team. It's really amazing, but it's really complicated.
这种建模可能非常复杂。例如，如果你看过 Scala 是如何编译到 JVM 的，如果你有那种，我想也许是不幸的去了解这些细节，这会是非常、非常复杂的。这是 Scala 团队真正绝妙的概念和工程工作。这真的很了不起，但这是 Scala 团队真正绝妙的概念和工程工作。这真的很了不起，但这也真的很复杂。
Sure, sure. Okay. So yeah, so when we have the static analysis tools and synthesis tools, and we have them per kind of thing someone is doing, I, I mean, I guess we can, we can sort of like keep moving up the stack. So you have your code base, right? So I have, I have my code base and how my code base behaves may be very different than Jason's code base. We do entirely different kinds of programming. So how did these tools sort of balance the, like, like you sort of said, the meat of the distribution, the sort of like average case versus the tailored case of, hey, on this project, we've made these, I don't want to say artistic, these opinion-based choices. You know, like how does the tooling sort of balance between those? Right. build some universal model, and that universal model captures how code behaves
当然，当然。好的。所以，当我们在进行静态分析工具和综合工具开发时，并且我们针对人们正在做的每种事情都有这些工具，我，我的意思是，我想我们可以，我们可以顺着技术栈继续向上推进。所以你有你的代码库，对吧？我有我的代码库，我的代码库的行为方式可能和杰森的代码库非常不同。我们做的是完全不同种类的编程。那么这些工具是如何在像你刚才说的分布的核心、那种平均情况，与定制化情况（即，嘿，在这个项目中，我不想说是艺术性的，但我们做出了这些基于主观意见的选择）之间取得平衡的呢？你知道的，工具是如何在这些之间进行平衡的呢？对吧，构建某种通用模型，而这个通用模型捕捉了代码的行为方式
in the, let's call it the common case, in the wild. Let's say I look at all the C++ projects on GitHub, and I will get some abstraction of what these projects do, how they're supposed to behave. I'll get some distribution of the expected code completions or code predictions that I need to do for these projects. They would work quite well for the majority of new C++ projects.
在通用的情况下，在野外的情况下。假设我查看 GitHub 上的所有 C++ 项目，我会对这些项目做什么、它们的预期行为是什么得到某种抽象。我会得到这些项目所需进行的预期代码补全或代码预测的某种分布。它们对于大多数新的 C++ 项目会相当管用。
But if you have made your own opinionated kind of decisions that are veering off significantly from, let's call it a general population, gen pop, then you would benefit greatly from training a custom model for your project, your organization to kind of capture these notions, right? And so the bigger your code base is, effectively, the more you would benefit from having your own private model to better capture how you do things, how your team is doing stuff. So then, I mean, I guess you're starting to veer, obviously,
但是，如果你做出了自己主观的决定，与所谓的普通人群、大众严重偏离，那么为你的项目、你的组织训练一个自定义模型来捕获这些概念，将会让你受益匪浅，对吧？所以，实际上，你的代码库越大，拥有自己的私有模型以更好地捕获你们做事的方式、你们团队做事的方式，你就会受益越多。所以，我的意思是，我想你开始偏离了，显然，
where we're going. But the static analysis, code completion, doesn't have to always be done by a trained system, right? I assume that prior, these were things that were hand done. So hand modeling, hand feature extraction, hand suggestion, and tuning, and then, you know. Yeah, that's exactly right.
我们要去的地方。但是静态分析、代码补全，并不一定总是由经过训练的系统来完成，对吧？我假设在此之前，这些都是人工完成的。所以人工建模、人工特征提取、人工建议和调整，然后，你知道的。是的，完全正确。
So maybe there's kind of a pause that we need to make here and kind of distinguish, I guess. I don't know if it's the second, third, or fourth wave. So I'll not put a number on kind of which wave is it of the static analysis tools. But let's call it the previous wave of static analysis tools. Uses hand-coded rules that say, oh, if you call foo and then you call bar, then this is really a bad idea.
所以也许我们需要在这里暂停一下，并区分一下，我想。我不知道这是静态分析工具的第二、第三还是第四波。所以我就不给这是第几波静态分析工具加数字了。但我们称之为前一波静态分析工具。它使用手工编写的规则，上面写着，哦，如果你调用了 foo 然后调用了 bar，这真的是个糟糕的主意。
Like if you check whatever Java to say, if X equals null and then the next line says X.foo, then this is not a good thing, right? Because you're likely to get a null reference. And so these are like hard-coded rules that capture the common case. They're manually crafted rules. And this is how like Linters, like ESLint work, right?
就像如果你检查任何 Java 代码，如果 X 等于 null，然后下一行说 X.foo，这可不是件好事，对吧？因为你很可能会遇到空指针引用。所以这些是捕捉常见情况的硬编码规则。它们是人工制作的规则。这就是像 ESLint 这样的 Linter 的工作方式，对吧？
They have like, I wanted to use like the S word, but they have a bunch of rules that were written over the years that capture a lot of like common anti-patterns and these may not be the anti-patterns for you and your project and this is why you get a ton of kind of complaints from these tools that because they're capturing generic things so that was like the previous generation of tools the new generation of tools is using ai to learn kind of what is it that is being done in your code base? What are the patterns?
它们有像——我想用那个以 S 开头的词，但它们有一堆历经多年编写的规则，捕捉了许多常见的不良模式（anti-patterns），而这些可能并不是你和你的项目的不良模式，这就是为什么你会从这些工具中听到大量的抱怨，因为它们捕捉的是通用事物。所以那是上一代工具。新一代工具正在使用人工智能来了解你的代码库中正在做什么？有哪些模式？
What are the anti-patterns? What are things that should be avoided? And it's actually using that information to give you much more targeted kind of alarms and reports on your code in case of checking and also much better predictions of what code should be written or how to complete your code when you're doing the program synthesis right so this is kind of like the difference between handcrafted things and learned things and that the reason that we can do that we can learn all these rich information about your project or about code in the universe is because of the progress that has been made in recent years in studying analysis technology in machine learning algorithms and models, and also in the computational power. So we're just, you know, we can throw huge GPUs and memory and data sets at the problem
有哪些不良模式？有哪些应该避免的事情？它实际上正在使用这些信息来对你的代码提供更有针对性的警报和报告（在检查的情况下），并且在进行程序综合时，还能对应该编写什么代码或如何补全代码提供更好的预测。所以这有点像手工制作的东西和学习到的东西之间的区别，我们能够做到这一点的原因——我们能够了解关于你的项目或宇宙中代码的所有这些丰富信息——是因为近年来在分析技术、机器学习算法和模型以及计算能力方面取得的进展。所以我们只是，你知道的，我们可以向这个问题投入巨大的 GPU、内存和数据集
and kind of train models that are able to capture information or rules that would otherwise have to be handwritten by experts. So when you're writing these handwritten rules you're saying you know this set of operations can cause like we talked about before overflow or underflow or undetermined behavior uh or it's my opinion that uh if you return a value you should always use that value and so like i say that's a rule right yeah so some set of experts deems you know sort sort of what is good or bad. What are the, you know, when you analyze code bases and, you know, sort of try to apply machine learning, you know, in my head, I'm trying to think like, how do you get those sort of quality metrics?
并训练出能够捕获信息的模型或规则，否则这些规则将不得不由专家手写。所以当你编写这些手写规则时，你说的是，你知道，这一组操作会导致像我们之前讨论过的那样，溢出或下溢或不确定行为，呃，或者依我之见，呃，如果你返回一个值，你就应该总是使用那个值，所以就像我说的那样，这是一个规则，对吧？是的——所以一组专家认为，你知道的，什么是好还是坏。当你分析代码库并尝试应用机器学习时，你知道的，在我的脑海里，我试图思考，你如何获得那些质量指标？
I mean, that the code compiles is insufficient, that the code runs is, I mean, maybe that's how you, that seems a bit tricky. Yeah, I think that the crux of the matter is, is specification at the end, right? Like the reason that I say a value that is being returned should be assigned somewhere. This is a specification, that's a property. And that property is probably kind of like a hygiene condition, right? It's like, it's something that is good to have regardless of what your program is doing. So that's kind of like a generic universal specification
我的意思是，代码能编译是不够的，代码能运行是——我的意思是，也许这就是你的方法，这看起来有点棘手。是的，我认为问题的核心最终是规范，对吧？就像我说应该在某个地方分配一个被返回的值的原因一样。这是一个规范，这是一个属性。而且这个属性可能有点像卫生条件，对吧？就像，不管你的程序在做什么，拥有它是件好事。所以这有点像通用的通用规范
that should hold anywhere, allegedly, right? And this is why we check it. And I don't know how to check for your program that, you know, a student class should always have the ID field assigned because as a general rule, I don't know what is a student. I don't know what is an ID. And I don't know even how to express this as a general rule.
据称它应该在任何地方都成立，对吧？这就是我们检查它的原因。我不知道如何为你的程序检查，你知道的，学生（student）类是否应该总是被分配 ID 字段，因为作为一般规则，我不知道什么是学生。我不知道什么是 ID。我甚至不知道如何将其表达为一般规则。
And I'm definitely not going to put it in the list of rules of ESLint to check across the universe because most of the universe does not have the class student and a field called id so this kind of like specialized specifications for your project for your setting are exactly what the machine learning algorithms can pick up and check for consistency of right and then more importantly with program synthesis, they can generate the right assignments to make sure that as you're doing these things, you always assign the idea of the student. They can make sure by construction that you're using these classes or using these pieces
而且我绝对不会把它放进 ESLint 的规则列表中去检查全宇宙，因为全宇宙的大部分并没有 student 这个类和名为 id 的字段。所以这种针对你的项目、你的环境的专用规范，正是机器学习算法可以挑选出来并检查其一致性的东西，对吧？更重要的是，通过程序综合，它们可以生成正确的赋值，以确保当你做这些事情时，你总是分配学生的 ID。它们可以通过构造确保你正在使用这些类或使用这些代码片段
of code the way they were intended. Today's sponsor is Rollbar. Rollbar is the leading platform that enables developers to proactively discover and resolve issues in their code, allowing them to work on continuous code improvement throughout the software development lifecycle. Rollbar has plans for all situations, from free to large enterprise. With Rollbar,
以它们原本意图的方式。今天的赞助商是 Rollbar。Rollbar 是领先的平台，使开发人员能够主动发现和解决代码中的问题，使他们能够在整个软件开发生命周期中致力于持续改进代码。Rollbar 针对从免费到大型企业的各种情况都制定了计划。通过 Rollbar，
developers deploy better software faster and can quickly recover from critical errors as they happen. We have a special URL at https://try.rollbar.com.pt for programming throwdown. There you can find two free ebooks, How Debugging is Changing and How Dev Experience Matters, as well as sign up for a free trial of Robar. Yeah, so maybe it's like, I'll use Jason's term I like here, double click on that for a second.
开发人员可以更快地部署更好的软件，并能在关键错误发生时迅速从中恢复。我们在 https://try.rollbar.com.pt 为 Programming Throwdown 提供了一个特殊的网址。在那里你可以找到两本免费电子书：《调试是如何改变的》以及《开发人员体验为何重要》，还可以注册免费试用 Rollbar。是的，所以也许就像，我借用杰森在这里喜欢用的词，双击一下这个。
We go into this that, okay, so I've seen this, you know, on, you know, Hacker News or Reddit or whatever. Someone trains a hidden Markov model over a code base and I can generate something that on first pass looks like code, right? So, and to kind of like unpack that a bit, it's not my field,
我们深入探讨这个，好吧，所以我在 Hacker News、Reddit 或其他地方看到了这个。有人在代码库上训练隐马尔可夫模型，我就可以生成一段初看起来像代码的东西，对吧？所以，为了稍微剖析一下，这不是我的领域，
but like what I understand about that is I can generate new code, which matches the pattern or statistics of your code base, right? So whenever you call this function, insert new student into database, everywhere in the code base, you do So whenever you call this function, insert new student into database, everywhere in the code base, you do that on the left hand side,
但我对它的理解是，我可以生成新的代码，它匹配你的代码库的模式或统计数据，对吧？所以每当你在代码库的任何地方调用这个函数：将新学生插入数据库时，你在左侧总是说：布尔值 successful 等于这个函数。我可以告诉你，当我发出这段代码时，我总是放一个布尔值 sick，但我不知道你为什么要这么做，或者为什么在另一种情况下，如果它是 50 对 50 的分摊，那么生成的代码会有 50% 的时间这样做，50% 的时间不这样做，对吧？就像我 50% 的时间不这样做。我可以匹配
you always say Boolean successful equals this function. And I can tell you when I emit this code, I always put Boolean sick, but I don't know why you do that or why in this other case, and if it's split 50-50, then the generation will 50% of the time do it, 50% not, right? Like I 50% not. I can match the
统计数据。所以我想人们可能用过这样的工具，他们见过这种模式匹配，或者，嘿，在这个文件的其他地方，你总是把这个词跟在那个词后面。我的意思是，我以前用过这些工具。我发现它们没那么有用。那么当你对这些模型进行这种训练时，目标是什么？它与仅仅匹配统计数据有什么不同？并且实际上像是你在暗示的那样做正确的事情？是的——所以，我认为这有点像自行车和飞船之间的区别，本质上它们有点像在做同一件事。它们就像交通工具，它们在移动东西，但其中一个比另一个要强大得多。这实际上归结于这样一个问题：这些模型在定制你进行预测的上下文的能力方面有多强大，
statistics. So I think people probably have used tools where they've seen that pattern matching or, hey, other places in this file, you always follow this word with that word. I mean, I've used those tools before. I didn't find them that useful. So what is the objective when you're doing this training of these models that differs from just sort of matching the statistics and actually sort of doing what you i think you were kind of alluding to like the right thing yeah so so i think it's kind of the difference between a bicycle and a spaceship at the essence they're kind of like you know doing the same thing. They're like vehicles, they're moving stuff, but one is just like insanely more powerful than the other. And really it becomes to a question of how powerful are these models in the ability to tailor the context in which you make the prediction
并在该上下文中进行泛化。所以我们有点，如今我们正在使用拥有数亿或数十亿参数的模型，拥有数十亿参数的神经网络来解决这里这种精确的预测问题，这里是像我
and generalize over that. And so we're kind of, these days we're using models with hundreds of millions or billions of parameters, neural networks with billions of parameters to solve kind of this exact predictive question of here's like the context
在编辑器中拥有的上下文，我接下来应该输入什么？这个模型不仅根据你编写的最后五个字进行上下文关联——这简直是无可救药的天真。它们根据你在文件中拥有的完整上下文进行上下文关联，包括自然语言，包括来自项目的其他外围信息，包括你在环境中拥有的各种其他信号，以便做出预测。这种能够进行上下文关联并在其上进行泛化的能力，正是赋予你非常准确的预测的魔力，这是人们赞赏并可以使用的，而不是仅仅，你知道的，我抛硬币然后建议下一个单词应该是，你知道的，
that I have in my editor and what is it that I should be typing next? And this model contextualized not only on, you know, the last five words that you wrote, which is like hopelessly naive. They contextualize on the entire context that you have in the file, including natural language, including other peripheral information from the project, including all sorts of other signals that you have in your environment in order to make a prediction. And this is kind of being able to contextualize and generalize over that is the magic that gives you really accurate predictions that people appreciate and can use, as opposed to just, you know, I flip a coin and I suggest that the next word should be either, you know,
foo 还是 bar，对吧？或者像，是的，你输入了 DB。我猜下一个单词要么是 add，要么是 remove，对吧？就像这样，所以它要复杂得多，这些模型比那要强大得多。那么，对于可能不太了解的人来说，我是说，这是否意味着你有一个混合系统
fool or bar, right? Or like, yeah, you did like DB. And I guess either the next word is add or remove, right? It's like, and so it's much more, the models are just like much more powerful than that. So are the, I guess like, you know, again, like for people who may not be aware, I mean, is it that you have a sort of hybrid system
你试图在这些模型中实际注入一些人类架构？还是你只是在建立问题并允许端到端的解决方案得到训练？是的，所以，你知道，在现实中，所有这些系统并不是真正的端到端，仅仅是因为端到端推理的工程成本
where you're trying to actually sort of like imbue some human architecture to these models? Or are you sort of just setting up the problem and allowing sort of an end-to-end solution to become trained? Yeah, so, you know, like in reality, all these systems are not really end-to-end just because of kind of the engineering cost of doing the inference end-to-end
通常是令人望而却步的，你需要结合几个模型以便及时得到响应。而且在使用语义信息时存在一些偏差。同样，有很多细节我不确定在这里讨论是否有用。但理想情况下，你希望它是完全端到端的。
is typically prohibitive, and you need to do a combination of several models in order to get the response on time. And then there's some bias using semantic information. And again, there are a ton of details that I'm not sure that this is useful to discuss here. But yeah, ideally, you would like to have it completely end to end.
但在实际工程的世界里，你需要做比这更复杂的事情。是的，这说得通。同样，我们正在接近实时综合的领域中工作，对吧？你正在输入东西，你必须在接近实时的时间内生成接下来会发生什么的预测，这样它才有用。
But in the world of practical engineering, you need to do something more sophisticated than that. Yeah, that makes sense. Again, we're working in the realm of near real-time synthesis, right? You're typing stuff, and you have to generate these predictions of what comes next in near time to be useful.
这就是工程变得非常巧妙的地方。这就是我要说的。所以，我的意思是，我想被给予无限的时间来给出建议是一回事，而我正在打字，你必须比我快，否则就没用了，又是另一回事。因此，正如你所提到的，我可以想象其中涉及的工程量，从“哦，嘿，我读了一篇学术论文，上面说，你知道，我们可以，你知道，以 X 百分的准确率建议代码补全”，到实际能够在 IDE 中交付它。所以也许花一分钟讨论一下。所以，你们已经
And this is where the engineering gets really clever. That's what I was going to say. So, I mean, I guess it's one thing to be given an infinite amount of time to make a suggestion versus I'm going to be typing it and you have to beat me to it or it's not useful. And so, as you mentioned, I can imagine the amount of engineering that goes in from, oh, hey, I read an academic paper that says, you know, we can, you know, you know, suggest code completion at an, you know, x percent accuracy to actually being able to deliver that in an IDE. So maybe to talk about that a minute. So, I mean, you guys have
构建了一个系统来做其中的一些事情。这就是为什么你们对这个考虑得这么多，并且，你知道，试图整合它。在架构层面上，你知道，这最终是如何运作的？所以，你知道，我在编辑器里打字，然后，你知道，屏幕上出现了文字。在幕后发生了什么？大概有五0万行 Rust 代码在底层运行，并进行非常高效的神经网络推理，其中涉及两到四个不同模型的组合，这些模型在响应时间和准确性方面具有不同的权衡。而且，你知道，如果你打字稍慢一点，工程师可能会赶上，你可能会得到稍好的预测，因为更强的模型及时生成了结果。如果没有，你可能会从稍逊一筹的模型中获得结果。而其中很多事情的真正挑战实际上是人类与
built a system to do some of this. This is, you know, why you've thought about this so much and, you know, trying to integrate it. At an architectural level, you know, how does that end up working? So, you know, I'm typing in my editor and, you know, words are appearing on screen. What's happening sort of in the background to there's kind of, I guess, half a million lines of Rust code that are running under the hood and doing very efficient neural network inference that involves between two and four different models that are being kind of combined together and have different trade-offs in terms of response time and accuracy. And, you know, if you're typing slightly slower, engineer may catch up and you may get slightly better predictions because the stronger model kind of made it in time. And if not, you may be getting results from a slightly inferior model. And the challenge really for a lot of it is actually the balance between the human and
机器之间的平衡。你如何在合适的地方做出不会打扰人类的预测？我们有点痴迷于寻找这种精确的平衡：何时进行预测、进行什么样的预测、在哪里进行预测、在把模型扔到你脸上之前模型的置信度应该是什么、在与人类交互之前还有什么其他类型的障碍？以及你如何以一种自然的方式融入人类的流（flow），以至于如果它没有帮助，人类真的可以轻松忽略它，而如果有帮助，则可以轻松消费它？好吧，这周围有很多内容。所以，是的。仅举一个例子，
the machine. How do you make predictions at the right places that do not interrupt the human right we're kind of obsessed uh on these exact kind of finding the balance of when to make predictions what kind of predictions to make where what should be the confidence from the model before we throw it in your face uh what other kind of barriers are there before you interact with the human? And how do you get into the flow of the human in a natural way such that really the human is kind of easily can easily ignore it if it's not helpful, but actually consume it if it is helpful? All right, and there's a lot around that. So yeah,. To pick maybe just even an example there,
在实践中，你们是如何处理这个问题的？我可以想到的一个例子是建议多少代码。所以，我可以补全你的一行。我可以建议你的函数。我可以建议你的整个程序。我的意思是，我们现在可能还不能编写程序。也许我们一会儿会讲到这一点。
how does that in practice, do you guys approach that problem? One example I can think of is how much code to suggest. So there's, I could complete your line. I could suggest your function. I could suggest your whole program. I mean, we can't probably program yet. Maybe we get there in a minute.
但是你们是如何平衡并试图弄清楚到底要在屏幕上显示多少代码的呢？对吧。幸运的是，我们已经做了一段时间了，而且我们一直在为数百万用户服务。所以我们实际上在野外运行了一些实验，以找出什么样的预测范围对人们最有用。这也取决于预期的，同样，这取决于上下文，但让我先把这个放在一边。
But how do you guys sort of balance off trying to figure out how much to end up sending up onto the screen? Right. So luckily, we've been doing this for a while, and we've been serving millions of users. So we actually run some experiments in the wild to find out, like, what kind of prediction of horizon is most useful for people. And it also depends on kind of the intended, again, it depends on context, but let me put that aside for a second.
事实证明，人类最喜欢的是他们能够对正确性做出快速判断的代码片段。因此，最有效的紧凑循环是人类写了某些东西，或者有足够的上下文，人类写了某些东西，然后机器建议了一些很容易被识别为有用的东西。比如，补全到行尾，但某种非常符合习惯用法（idiomatic）的东西。
It turns out that what humans like the most is pieces of code that they can make snap judgments about the correctness of. So the kind of the tight loop that works best is the human writes something or there's sufficient context, the human writes something and the machine suggests something that is easily identifiable as useful. So like kind of, let's say complete to the end of the line, but something that is very idiomatic.
所以如果你看到了，你就会知道，是的，这正是我的意思，对吧？所以这正是我们在内部所说的“提醒我”（remind me）模型，对吧？这有点像我写过 8 万次的代码。我知道我要写什么。如果我问旁边的人，他们知道我要写什么如果我问旁边的人，他们知道我要写什么，就像我对此的经典例子是，逐行读取 Python 文件，这就像我不知道在我的生活中写过多少次的代码，可能在我的一生中写过数千次，对吧？如果我看到了，我知道它是正确的，我不需要去深思熟虑
So if you see it, you will know that, yeah, that's what I meant, right? So this is kind of what we call internally the remind me model, right? It's kind of code that I've written 80,000 of times. I know what I'm going to write. If I ask a human next to me, they know what i'm going to write if i ask a human next to me they know what i'm going to write like my my classical example for that is uh read the python file line by line that's like a code i wrote i don't know how many times in my life probably thousands of times in my life right and if i see it i know that it's correct i don't need to kind of ruminate
关于它，就像是的，就是这样。所以这不需要去深思熟虑。就像，是的，就是这样。所以这正是那种我可以补全多于一行的经典情况，因为它非常符合习惯用法。当你看到它时，你就知道它是那个。这就是你需要的。这有点像你从 Stack Overflow 复制的代码，对吧？这就是
about it it's like yeah that's it and so that don't need to kind of ruminate about it. It's like, yeah, that's it. And so that's kind of the classic case in which I can complete more than one line because it's really idiomatic. When you see it, you know it's that. It's what you need. It's kind of code that otherwise you would copy from Stack Overflow, right? That's kind of the
符合习惯用法的思考方式，对吧？所有这一切都是在开发人员的本地机器上进行的。然后这种拆分是如何进行的呢？显然，有些东西可能需要在某个服务器上运行。是的，所以在技术上我们所做的，
idiomatic thing to think about it, right? And so all of this is happening sort of local on the developer's machine. And then how does that split happen? Obviously, some stuff probably needs to happen in a server somewhere. Yeah, so what we do technically,
我们在 Tab9 中做的是，允许你配置架构或你想要运行的配置。你可以完全在本地运行，甚至是在隔离的空气隙环境（air-gapped）中，这样你就可以完全不通过网络运行。或者你可以在云端运行部分推理，这显然能给你带来更好的补全，因为你运行的是比你的机器上仅 CPU 推理更强大的 GPU。
what we do in Tab9 is we allow you to configure the architecture or the kind of configuration that you'd like to run in. You can run everything completely locally, even air-gapped, so you can run it without network at all. Or you can run some of the inference on the cloud, which obviously gives you better completions because you run with stronger GPUs than what you would otherwise have CPU-only inference on your machine.
或者你可以完全在 Tab9 云上运行，并且你可以控制它，你可以在你的组织中创建你自己的服务器并运行它。所以基本上，你可以控制部署哪种模型以及你想将它们部署在哪里。我认为这对于开发人员能够控制推理发生的位置非常有用，特别是由于推理确实需要来自你的 IDE 的一些上下文，对吧？所以你可能会相当敏感
Or you can run completely on tab 9 cloud and you control, you can create your own server in your organization and run it. So you basically, you can control which kind of models are being deployed and where do you want to deploy them. I think that's really useful for developers to be able to control where inference happens, especially because inference does require some context from your IDE, right? So you may be quite sensitive
关于这些东西被发送到哪里，这主要取决于你的工作场所的政策。是的，这可能会有很大的差异。所以在我们深入探讨——你知道的，讨论 Tab9 具体内容之前，我这里的最后一个评论是，你提到试图找出会有多少波，而你拒绝给出一个数字，这没关系。但展望未来，我的意思是，你认为未来会怎样？自从我在学校以来，每个人总是说，哦，也许有一天我们只需要，你知道的，
to where this stuff is being sent, depending mostly on policy of your workplace. Yeah, that can vary wildly. So before we dive into like, you know, talking about tab nine specifically, sort of my last comment here is you mentioned trying to maybe come up with how many waves and you refuse to give a number, which is fine. But then like going forward, I mean, what do you sort of see the future? I mean, since I was in school, everyone always said, oh, maybe one day we'll just, you know,
告诉计算机我们想要什么，它就会，你知道的，为我们编写程序。人们对这种说法嗤之以鼻。而且，你知道，也许这并不是最终形成的未来。但是，我的意思是，这没关系，这可能非常具有主观意见。但是，如果我们展望未来 10 年、20 年，你认为开发人员与他们的代码交互的方向会是什么？所以我认为，首先，可以相当有把握地说，两三年后，所有的代码都将以这样或那样的方式受到人工智能的影响。
tell the computer what we want and it'll just, you know, write the program for us. And people scoff at that. And, you know, maybe that's not exactly the future that that shaped up. But I mean, and it's fine that this probably gets highly into opinion. But, you know, if we sort of look maybe enough out sort of 10 years, you know, 20 years, what do you think will be the direction we head in for how developers interact with their code? So I think, first of all, it is pretty safe to say that two or three years down the line, all code will be touched by AI in one way or another.
要么它将由 AI 部分生成，要么它将由 AI 审查，或者测试将由 AI 生成。AI 将做一些事情来自动化工作中的平凡部分，对吧？有那么多重复的工作正在进行，其中很多实际上可以而且应该通过现有的 AI 机制来自动化。我相信这已经在发生了，并且随着这些工具变得更加主流，它将会加速。所以我觉得这是一个很容易做出的预测，而且我对此深信不疑。展望未来 10 年，这真的是纯粹的推测和主观意见。我认为在特定领域中，你将会看到大量的自动化。
Either it will be generated by AI in parts, or it will be reviewed by AI, or tests will be generated by AI. Something will be done by AI to automate the mundane parts of the job, right? There are so many repetitive work being done, and a lot of it really can be and should be automated by existing AI machinery. And I believe that this is already happening and it's going to accelerate as these tools become more mainstream. So I think that's like an easy prediction to make and I hold it very strongly. Looking 10 years down the line, this is really like speculation and opinion. I think in specific domains, it is going to be the case that you're going to see a lot of automation.
比如，如果你正在做的是为特定领域的 UI 编写组件，对吧？我知道医疗设备的 UI，对吧？它必须非常具体。它之所以必须如此的原因是，然后很多事情可以从意图（intent）中自动化。它之所以必须具体或领域具体，是因为，同样，这一切都是关于意图的问题。作为一个人类，我如何向机器表达意图？而这个意图永远只会是非常局部的，对吧？否则，我将不得不向机器编写大量的意图。而这个意图永远只会是局部的，对吧？否则，我将不得不写一大堆英文散文来表达我想要的是什么。而这些英文散文将是模棱两可的。而这些英文散文将
Like if what you're doing is writing components for UI of a particular area, right? I know UI for medical devices, right? It has to be very specific. And the reason that it has to be, then a lot can be automated from intent. The reason that it has to be specific or domain specific is because, again, it's all a question of intent. How do I express as a human the intent to the machine? And this intent is always going to be very partial, right? Otherwise, I'm going to have to write a lot of the intent to the machine. And this intent is always going to be very partial, right? Otherwise, I'm going to have to write a lot of English prose to express what is it that I want. And this English prose is going to be ambiguous. And this English prose is going to
比实际的代码更难调试。所以我不相信通用编程会被英语取代。这听落荒谬。也许我错了。但在领域特定的事情中，我认为我们会看到更多的自动化，但它不会是……我推测它会更顺应低代码、无代码的习惯用法，你知道的……是的，是的。
be harder to debug than actual code. So I don't believe that in general purpose programming is ever going to be replaced by English. That sounds preposterous to me. Maybe I'm wrong. But in domain-specific things, I think we're going to see a lot more automation, but it's not going to be... I conjecture that it's going to be more along the kind of low-code, no-code idioms that, you know... Yeah, yeah.
从某种意义上说，它类似于 Wix 做网站，对吧？如果你在做网站设计，你无需编写一行代码就能完成很多工作。但这是一个特定领域的系统，当你没有提供合理的默认值时，它可以假设合理的默认值，对吧？所以你可以向 Wix 提供几乎为零的信息，它就会做出合理的事情，因为默认值已经内置到系统中了。
It's similar to Wix, in a sense, doing website, right? If you're doing website design, you can get a lot done without writing a single line of code. But this is kind of domain specific system that can assume sensible defaults when you don't provide them, right? And so you can provide zero information almost to Wix and it will do something sensible because the defaults have been baked into the system.
我认为这种情况会越来越多地涌现，更多的领域将被自动化，我认为会带有这种风格。至于将永远存在的通用编程，我认为任何人都不必担心他们的工作。工作很大程度上在于发现规范，而不是实现规范。没有哪个开发人员会得到五页纸的函数英文描述然后去实现它，对吧？他们得到的是更高水平的规范，而他们实际做的是从中雕刻出
And this is going to pop up more and more for more domains are going to be automated, I think, in that flavor. And for general purpose programming, which is always going to be around, I don't think anyone should be worried about their job. The job is so much about specification discovery and not about specification implementation. It's not like no developer gets like five pages of English descriptions of the function and then goes to implement it, right? They get the higher level specification and what they actually do is like carve out
带有所有细节的真实规范。编程实际上是关于发现规范。它不是关于将英语翻译成代码。顺着你刚才的话发挥一下，我的意思是，我认为我们必须走到那一步。原因是我注意到的一件事而且它说得通，那就是当我们说程序员时，我的意思是，我们倾向于认为，你知道，某人处于，
the real specification with all the details from it. And programming is about specification discovery, really. It's not about translating English to code. Just to riff on like what you're saying, I mean, I think we have to get there. And the reason why is because something I've noticed happening and it makes sense is when we say programmer, I mean, we tend to think about, you know, someone at a,
他们叫什么来着？我总是忘记最新的缩写是什么，但是像硅谷公司、初创公司什么的。但在实践中，在这些区域之外编写代码的人数远多于内部。我认为随着软件渗透到一切事物中，这种情况将继续增长。我几天前才和一位绅士交谈，他说，嗯，我有这个想法，但是，你知道，我不知道怎么找程序员，我只是在想，是的，
what do they call it? I always forget what the latest acronym is, but like a Silicon Valley company or startup or whatever. But in practice, there are way more people writing code outside of those areas than in an inside. And I think that's going to continue to grow as software permeates just everything. I was talking to a gentleman just like a few days ago and he was saying, well, I have this idea, but like, you know, I don't know how to find programmers and I'm just thinking like, yeah, like,
我的意思是，你说的听起来很酷，但，你知道，你将不得不说服一个可以拿到更高报酬的人去做一些更有价值的事情。这并不是说你的想法不好。这只是像，而且我当时非常——我没那样说，对吧？但就像，并不是你的想法不好。这只是像，你不是，它是如此小众，
I mean, what you're saying sounds cool, but like, you're going to have to convince somebody who can be paid a lot more to do something a lot more worthwhile. And that's not to say your idea isn't. It's just like, and I was very, I didn't say that, right? But like, it's not that your idea is bad. It's just like, you're not, it's so niche
以至于那里的回报永远不会足够大，无法支付，你知道的，别人能在这些其他可寻址市场更大的公司中做的事情。因此，当你看到每家公司都需要编写一定数量的程序和开发软件时，我们必须共同弄清楚，或者我想象有人共同弄清楚如何
that like the return there is just never going to be big enough to pay, you know, someone what, you know, they can do, you know, at one of these other, you know, larger addressable market companies. And so I think as you look across just every company needing, you know, some amount of programs to be written and software to be developed, we have to figure out collectively, or I guess someone figuring out collectively how to like,
赋能人们以可以更容易地进行培训的水平来编写程序，而不是要求这种，你知道的，学术背景，你称之为通用编程。我认为这是一个公平的术语，你知道的，能够完全调试某事，编写完全自定义的全新代码（greenfield code），你知道的，诸如此类的事情，而是转而产出某种东西的另一个版本并做出微小的调整。而且，夫妻店（mom and pop shops）里的人必须能够做到这一点。而类似于你所说的是实现这一点的方式。我不知道这是否是实现它唯一的方式，但这是一种我们实现这种分层的方式，在这种分层中，编程变成了一个更加广泛的术语，从
empower people to do program writing at the level that can be trained more easily, rather than requiring this, you know, sort of academic background, you call it a sort of general purpose program. I think it's a fair term for it, you know, being able to fully debug something, write completely custom greenfield code, you know, this kind of stuff, but instead just turn out another version of something and make small tweaks. And, you know, people in mom and pop shops are going to have to be able to do that. And something like you're saying is a way that happens. don't know it's the way it happens but it's a way we sort of get this stratification where programming becomes a much more diffuse term all the way from
这种低代码无代码，一直到人们，你知道的，为 3A 级电子游戏标题的刷新率微秒级改进而优化汇编语言。我认为还有另一个趋势肯定会变得更加强大，那就是让编程在总体上更加宽容。我编写一个程序，
this sort of low code no code down to the people you know optimizing assembly interlux for you know microsecond improvements on you rates of AAA video game titles. I think there's another trend that will for sure become stronger, which is making programming more forgiving in general. I write a program,
它应该运行并做一些事情。我们在从 C、C++ 转向 Python、JavaScript 方面取得了巨大的进展，对吧？编写出 Hello World 的障碍，对吧？编写出 Hello World 的时间在使用这些语言时已经大大缩短了。我认为我们将看到更多这样的情况，
it should run and do something. And we've made huge progress moving from C, C++ to like Python JavaScript, right? The barrier to get hello world, right? The time to hello world has shrunk considerably moving to these languages. And I think we're going to see more of that
通过环境也做出一些合理的假设。如果你正在做的是使用 Vue、React 或任何编写网站前端的最新酷炫事物来编写某个网站，那么可以做出合理的默认值，从而简化现在必须完成的大量苦差事。我认为这是另一个在人工智能的协助下将继续增长的趋势，因为你确实需要某种智能来弄清楚如何处理那里的复杂性。是的，我看到的一件非常酷的事情是，我的意思是，我最早是在 Wolfram Alpha 上看到这一点的，现在有一些初创公司也在这样做，但基本上是查询知识库的方法，比如查询数据库。你会看到诸如“给我所有瑞士人的平均收入，所有瑞士客户的平均收入”之类的事情。仅凭那句英语句子。所以正如你所说，那是高度领域特定的东西。如果你只有一个名为 Foo 的任意数据库，并且所有列都叫 bar 和 baz，他们什么也做不了，但它可以提取出独特的东西，比如“哦，这一列叫国家（country），我知道当人们创建一个名为国家的列时，我可以假设他们要做什么”，所以，是的，你开始在数据库和这些查询中看到这一点，我认为这只是时间问题，它也会扩展到代码。
by the environment making also some sensible assumptions. If what you're doing is writing like some website using Vue, React, whatever is the latest cool thing to write website frontends, then there are sensible defaults that could be made, simplifying a lot of the grunt work that has to be done right now. I think this is another trend that will continue to grow with the assistance of AI, because you do need some sort of intelligence to figure out how to deal with the complexities there. Yeah, one thing I've seen that's been really cool is, I mean, I saw this first with Wolf
是的，你开始看到它了，但它总是超级微妙。至少从我所看到的来看，你用英语写了这个，然后说，但是等等，当我说是瑞士时，我到底是什么意思？我的意思是也包括意大利属于，你知道的，在瑞士工作的那部分人，
from Alpha, and now there are some startups doing it, but basically ways to query knowledge stores, like query databases. And you're seeing things like, give me the average revenue for all the people in Switzerland, all the customers in Switzerland. And just from that English sentence. So that's, as you said, that's something very domain specific. If you just have an arbitrary database called Foo and all the columns are called bar and baz like they can't do anything but but it can pull out unique things like oh this column is called country and and i just know when people make a column called country i can assume what they're going to do and so yeah you're starting to see this with databases and and those queries and i think it's just a matter of time before it gets to code as well.
还是只有瑞士公民，或者到底是什么意思？就像你陷入了所有这些微妙之处，而这实际上是开发人员的工作，需要回过头来说，但是等等，这里其实有个问题。是这个国家的公民，
Yeah, you're starting to see it, but it's always super subtle. And from what I've seen, at least, you write this in English and then say, but wait, when I said Switzerland, what exactly did I mean? Did I mean like also the part of Italy that is, you know, working in Switzerland
还是在这个国家工作的人，或者你使用的这些术语的确切定义是什么？这正是编程语言不让你模棱两可的地方。是的，这说得通。这就回到了你的代码综合。就像，好吧，你知道的，我见过 10,000 人
or only Swiss citizens or what exactly? It's like you become in all these subtleties that it's actually a job of the developer to kind of go back and say but wait, there's actually a question here. Is it the citizens of the country or
问同一个问题，其中 9,900 人有这些假设。所以我们可以使用统计数据来只给人们提供一个原型。然后他们仍然必须查看它，但我们会经常猜对，以至于它超级有用。这就像 Alexa。你知道，Alexa，你知道的，我的父母有很重的意大利口音。所以 Alexa 现在大概能听懂他们说的话的 90%，这太棒了。过去是 0%。
people who work in the country or what exactly is the definition of these terms that you're using? And this is exactly is the definition of these terms that you're using, right? And this is exactly where the programming language doesn't let you be ambiguous. Yeah, that makes sense. And this gets back to your code synthesis. Like, well, you know, I've seen 10,000 people
但在某个时候，它爬升了上去。甚至在它达到 90% 之前，它就达到了变得有用的程度。有一个临界点，他们可以只告诉 Alexa，设置一个计时器或设置计时器什么的。我模仿妈妈的口音太糟糕了。对不起，妈妈。但他们的确会说，设置一个计时器之类的。而且它的准确度足够高，以至于当它出错时，他们只需要再试一次或使用手机什么的。而且它仍然是一个净正生产力。太酷了。好吧，我们来谈谈 Tab9。所以给我们介绍一下
ask the same question, and 9,900 of them had these assumptions. So we can use statistics to just give people a prototype. And then they'll still have to look at it, but we'll get it right so often that it's super useful. It's like Alexa. You know, Alexa, you know, my parents have like a thick Italian accent. And so Alexa gets maybe 90% of what they say right now, which is amazing. It used to be 0%.
问了同样的问题，其中 9900 个都有这些假设。因此我们可以利用统计数据给出一个原型。然后人们仍然需要去查看它，但由于我们准确率极高，它会变得超级有用。就像 Alexa 一样。你知道的，Alexa，我父母有很浓的意大利口音。所以现在 Alexa 大概能听懂他们 90% 的话，这太惊人了。以前是 0%。
But at some point, it climbed up. And even before it hit 90%, it got to the point where it became useful. There was a crossover point to where they could just tell Alexa, set a timer or set the timer or whatever. I did a terrible mom accent. Sorry, mom. But they do set a timer or whatever. I did terrible mom accent. Sorry, mom. But they do like, you know, set a timer or something like that. And it's correct enough that they, you know, when it's wrong, they just to try again or use their phone or something. And it's still a net positive productivity. Yeah. Cool. Well, let's talk about about tab nine for a minute. So tell us a bit
但在某个时刻，准确率上升了。甚至在达到 90% 之前，它就已经达到了变得有用的程度。存在一个临界点，在这个点上，他们可以告诉 Alexa 设置一个定时器或者做类似的事情。我模仿了我妈那糟糕的口音。对不起，妈妈。但他们确实会设置定时器或做类似的事情。而且它的准确度足够高，以至于当它出错时，他们只需再试一次，或者使用手机什么的。这仍然是一个净增的生产力。是的。酷。好吧，我们来谈谈 Tab Nine。给我们介绍一下吧
about what it's like to to work at tab nine are you guys currently like wholly remote i mean the world's a crazy place these days uh how are you guys sort of handling that and uh yeah yeah so we're mostly working remotely due to kind of covid restrictions uh we do have a physical office which is is mostly empty, I guess. But people do come in. Yeah, we have some remote people in the US as well. And we're always hiring interesting talent. On hiring, do you guys do internships? What kind of background are you looking for from people?
关于在 Tabnine 工作是什么体验，你们目前是完全远程的吗？我的意思是现在世界挺疯狂的，呃，你们是怎么处理的，还有，呃，是的，是的，由于某种新冠限制，我们大部分时间都在远程办公，我们确实有一个实体办公室，不过基本上是空的，我想是的。但人们确实会来。是的，我们在美国也有一些远程员工。而且我们一直在招聘有趣的杰出人才。关于招聘，你们招实习生吗？你们希望应聘者具备什么样的背景？
I think internships are, again, really hard to do do remote i think you're missing a lot of the experience and the immersion and like meeting a lot of people and so i'm not a huge fan that the current uh climate let's call it so watch this space okay yeah exactly but but uh definitely Yeah, exactly. But definitely interesting. And we're always hiring people who have like an LPL background, like machine learning programming languages background. Tab9 works on the intersection of programming languages and machine learning on representations of code and learning models of code and doing efficient inference for models of code and learning models of code and doing efficient inference for models of code
我认为实习生，同样，远程做实习非常困难，我觉得你错过了很多体验、沉浸感以及结识很多人，所以我不是特别喜欢目前这种呃气候，让我们这么叫它，所以拭目以待吧。好的，是的，完全正确。但绝对很有趣。我们一直在招聘拥有 PL 背景的人，比如机器学习、编程语言背景。Tabnine 从事的是编程语言和机器学习的交叉领域，涉及代码表示、代码学习模型、为代码模型进行高效推理等类似的事情。我们可能是以色列最大的 Rust 团队。我们为自己是 Rust 爱好者而感到非常自豪，并且坦白说，还使用 Rust 以及实际上还有汇编语言来处理各种底层推理代码。是的，我的意思是，这本身就很迷人。关于 Rust 以及关于，你知道的，这种低延迟响应时间之类的事情，我有很多问题。
and stuff like that. We're kind of probably the biggest Rust shop in Israel. And we take a lot of pride in being Rust and Rust enthusiasts and dealing also with all sorts of low level inference code using Rust and also assembly, actually, to be honest. Yeah, I mean, that's fascinating in itself. I have many questions about Rust and about, you know, this sort of like low latency response time things are very interesting.
我认为这是一个增长领域。无论如何，没时间深入探讨了。时间快到了。所以，是的，人们怎么试用 Tab9 呢？它到底是什么？
I think that's an area of growth. Anyways, can't get into that. We're running out of time. So, yeah, how can't get into that. We're running out of time. So, yeah, how can people try out Tab9? Like, what is it?
人们能够使用它吗？它贵得离谱吗？它到底是怎么运作的？是的，所以 Tab9 完全是免费的。如果你是一个开发者，你现在就可以下载它，
Are people able to use it? Is it cost an arm and a leg? How does it kind of work? Yeah, so Tab9 is completely free. If you're like a developer, you can download it now,
安装它，并完全免费地使用它。这个免费产品非常强大且实用。正如我们所说，有数百万开发者正在他们的 IDE 中使用它。我认为免费版真的非常、非常强大，几乎可以说是过于强大了。
install it, and use it completely free forever. The free product is very powerful and useful. and we have millions of developers using it in their IDE as we speak. I think it's really, really powerful that the free is almost too powerful, the free version.
这可能带有主观色彩，但确实如此。不，说真的。但是如果你在一个团队中工作，帕特里克，这正好切合你刚才所说的话，你会从为你的团队训练模型中获益匪浅。而这些私有模型正是 Tab9 最终赚钱的方式。我们为团队训练私有模型，你只需连接你的代码库，就会为你的团队完全自动地交付一个私有模型，它了解你团队的习惯用法、词汇、实体以及你们代码库中正在发生的事情，并为你提供针对你做事方式量身定制的更好补全。
That might be biased, but yeah. No, I'm serious, actually. But if you are working in a team, you get exactly to what you said earlier, Patrick, that you would benefit greatly from training a model for your team. And these private models are how Tab9 makes money at the end. We train private models for teams and you just connect your repo and you get a private model delivered completely automatically for your team that knows the kind of the idioms of your team and the vocabulary you know the entities and what's going on in your code base and gives you much better tailored completion
你还可以自定义它，比如设置：“哦，你知道的，不要在那段遗留代码上进行训练。我们其实正试图摆脱它。”没错。如果你继续在它上面训练，你就会得到这种效应。是的，你会得到那种你永远无法摆脱的遗留代码的“木星级”引力，对吧？是的，我的意思是，每当我们将我们的代码行数统计指向——
completions for how you do stuff and you can also customize it to say things like, oh, you know, don't train on that legacy code. We're actually trying to escape that. Yeah, sure. If you keep training on it, you get like this effect. Yeah, you get the Jupyter level kind of gravity of the legacy code that you could ever escape, right? Yeah, I mean, that's like anytime we point our code count at,
我们使用 Protocol Buffers，它会生成大量的代码，你的代码行数统计会被所有这些自动生成的代码淹没。我认为在那里，你知道，过去我总是认为，“哦天哪，这东西太贵了。这些开发工具太贵了。”但现在，开始更多地带着管理者的角度去思考时，
we use protocol buffers and it generates tons of code and your line of code count is swamped by all this auto-generated code. And I think there that, you know, it used to be, I always thought, you know, oh man, stuff's expensive. These developer tools are expensive. But then now like starting to think a bit more with a manager hat,
我意识到实际上程序员的时间非常昂贵。任何能帮助人们提高速度、不破坏代码以及不犯错误的东西。哦等等，我觉得我引用错了。无论如何，你知道，任何你能在这个领域帮助到人们的地方，都是极其有价值的。我认为人们正在意识到，
I realized actually like programmer time is very expensive. Anything that helps people sort of go faster and not break things and make mistakes. Oh wait, I think I'm misquoting. Anyways, you know, anytime you can sort of help people in that domain, like it's enormously valuable. And I think people are catching up
程序员的效率是一个巨大的瓶颈。这是一个巨大的瓶颈。我们看到，使用 Tabnine 后有很大的改进，根据你的编码中所谓世俗（常规）部分的比例，用户报告生产力提升了 15% 到 30% 不等。或者如果你使用的是包含大量样板代码的语言，比如 Java，就会浮现在脑海中。那么它真的、真的很管用。如果你在编写前端代码，它极其有用。我认为就语言而言，
that like programmer efficiency is a huge bottleneck. It's a huge bottleneck. And we see, you know, a lot of improvement when using tab nine, like users report between 15 to 30% improvement in their productivity, depending, again, it depends on how, let's call it, mundane part of your coding is. Or if you're using very languages that contain a lot of boilerplate and Java comes to mind, for example. Then it's really, really useful. If you're writing front-end code, it's extremely useful. I think in terms of languages,
我们的分发情况大概是 JavaScript、Python 和 Java，我想这可能是 Tabnine 用户使用率最高的三种语言。是的，我认为它在所有语言中都非常有用，但这三种语言的采用率极高。还有 PHP，我认为还有 PHP 和 Rust。我们自己显然也在 Rust 上使用它。你刚才提到的这件事也，
our distribution is kind of JavaScript, Python, and Java, I think maybe are the top three languages of tab nine users. Yeah, I think it's extremely useful in all languages, but these three see like huge adoption. Also PHP and I think PHP and Rust. We use it ourselves, obviously, for Rust. This thing that you kind of alluded to also
引起了我的兴趣，因为这也是从管理者角度出发的思考。人们很少谈论它，而且成本相当高，那就是当你把新人带入项目时，即使他们知道自己在做什么，让他们通过代码评审来适应各种习惯用法、风格以及所有这些，那些新人编写代码所需的时间，可能还比不上其他人评审和纠正代码所花的小时数，甚至是一对一的比例。
intrigues me because this is, again, thinking with Manager Hat. It's sort of not talked about, and it's pretty expensive, which is when you bring new people onto the project, even if they know what they're doing, like getting them adapted to the sort of idioms and styles and all of that through code review, takes probably even more than one-to-one number of hours for those new people to write the code, of people to review and correct the code.
但这也是令人沮丧的。这是一个，你要与之抗争的事情，这不是私事，当自尊心介入时，这会消耗团队大量的工时来带新人，所以拥有一个陪伴在你身边的工具，能够以一种低自尊风险的方式鼓励你编写符合规范的代码，我的意思是，实际上这超级令人兴奋。是的，这是低自尊的。而且它一直陪伴着你，在这个意义上，你不会在代码评审时才遭到猛烈抨击，对吧？
But it's also frustrating. It's a, you battle sort of like, this isn't a personal thing like egos come in like it's a very expensive number of hours drain on the team thing to bring new people up so having a tool that sits alongside of you and sort of like in a in a low ego risk way sort of encourages you to write conformant code i mean to, this actually is super exciting. Yeah, it's low-ego. And also, it's there for you in the sense that you don't reach the code review and get slammed, right?
因为你已经得到了某种……最坏的情况也就是你做了常规的做法，对吧？所以在某种程度上，它能让你真正发挥出超水平的表现，因为你知道，我至少和平均水平一样糟糕，我不会低于那个水平，而且实际上我认为要好得多。使用 Tabnine 时发生的一个有趣的事情是，当你看到建议时，有时也会让你思考，比如当我使用 Tab 9 时，我得到了一些建议，心想：等等，这不是我原本打算这样做的方式，那么我漏掉了什么？
Because you already get something that is... The worst case is that you've done the common thing, right? So it lets you really punch above your weight in a sense right because like you know i'm at least as as bad as as as the average i will not fall below that and i think actually much better and an interesting thing that happens with tab nine is that when you see the suggestion it also makes you think sometimes, like when I use tab 9, I get some suggestions like, but wait, that's not the way I intended
事实上，结果往往是好几次都出现了一个我甚至不知道的新 API，对吧？人们开始使用它，而我想，我好久没碰过那个了，所以即使你最终没有使用它，也能在那里有所发现，
to do this, so what am I missing? And actually, it turned out several times that there was just a new API that I didn't know about, right? And people started using, but I'm like, I haven't touched that for a long time, so discovery there, even if you end up not using it,
只要意识到这个东西变了就非常有趣。这也让你对正在发生的事情有了个全局了解，对吧？在你编写那些你原本不会察觉到的东西时。所以这是另一个方面。不错。因此，在节目简介中，我们会附上指向 Tab9、他们的 Twitter 账号以及 Aaron 的 Twitter 账号的链接。如果你有任何问题或想联系他，
just being aware that this thing has changed is really interesting. And this also kind of gives you a picture of what's going on, right? As you're programming things that you would not be aware of otherwise. So that's another aspect of that. Nice. So in the show notes, we'll have a link to Tab9, to their Twitter handle, to Aaron's Twitter handle. If you have any questions or reach out to him
或者你想查看这款产品，我的意思是，这超级令人兴奋。我要去试用一下，尽管你没有说出我最喜欢的语言。我们要去看看效果如何，然后体验一把。但我度过了一段非常愉快的时光。谢谢你来参加我们的节目。非常感谢邀请我。我度过了一段非常愉快的时光，非常感谢邀请我，我玩得很开心。
or you want to check out the product, I mean, it's super exciting. I'm going to go try it, even though you didn't name my favorite languages. We're going to go see how this goes and give it a whirl. But I had a very enjoyable time. Thank you for coming on with us. Thank you so much for having me. I had a very enjoyable time thank you for coming on with us thank you so much for having me i had a lot of fun
音乐由 Eric Barn Dollar 提供，《Programming Throwdown》根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议发布。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输本作品，进行混音和改编，但您必须对我和帕特里克进行署名，并且
music by eric barn dollar programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I, and
以相同方式共享。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
同类共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。